all right four people joining this
livestream this is a design review of
new functionality in we seem to have
somebody who needs to be muted by the
way um functionality and geometric
computing and this looks like a mega
design review which I can't imagine my
gonna get done the next hour but let's
at least start uh Wow okay
all right so should I be running this in
the prototype build or is it not
worthwhile there's no point in this
particular file being run okay but I
don't know whether I can run jockey
tools in the prototype builds um but
what should I do here so right should I
look at okay what where should I look
here should I look in polygon guide
slash polygons new or what sorry I was
okay can I just talk you through it a
little bit first and then we start
looking okay okay so and the two big by
the way I'm sorry whoever's who is
project managing here is it man ooh yes
okay so you should report that in the
prototype build here I think this is a
prototype build it is unbelievably slow
to type in the search field here and now
it says it can't find it no because it's
it's it's only in source okay they're
not built you know that's what we call
them before we transfer it oh yeah
that's fine okay now so so first of all
this this first section here you want
might want to browse through it if you
close that polygon before before opening
just close to polygon sales so you can
see the bigger structure the big polygon
that one okay that's polyhedron closed
at
I already looked through this oh you did
okay so you have a sense I have a sense
there's a lot of stuff here looks water
there's a lot of stuff okay
okay so let's okay so first point is
polygons with holes and other such
things that's correct
Wow a lot of interesting stuff here
really interesting stuff okay okay cool
polyhedra same story there de polyhedra
with voids as well as named polyhedra
which we've already got coherent data
but that's presumably now feeding into
these polyhedra right
yesterday they will be able to return
those and we have a new thing called
uniform polyhedron which is one of those
easy constructors okay as well as and I
realized that it's not added here cause
we forgot the Platonic solids we've
we've introduced ptosis just standard
name so icosahedra is sir icosahedron is
just a thing now it's just a thing now
but that's just five of them you know
yeah I understand now always just be 5
of them he says no I'm just joking
ok there definitely will ok so then if I
say graphics 3d of that ok and that
presumably has like a like a sphere it
presumably has something where I can say
0 0 0 7 or something
what's with 7 - does the radius probably
open do know a French page and that
would be the consistent thing to do
wouldn't it but that's what we've done
for many other kinds of things
you
and that says icosahedra shall I fix
that okay you can fix that its future
eyes anyway it's correct even you know
it says represents a collection of
iconic oh you're right Dora he drew yes
yes yes and those p20 0 well they're not
sorry P 20 is correct it's the dual I
don't quite understand this what what I
don't understand how this aggregates
here but we've got a bunch of background
noise but um I don't really understand
how that's aggregated there so first in
term of modeling the you know the Parma
tradition is term of the length of the
edge Center at 0 0 on the start usage
give you the occultation you know Theta
Phi yeah on do you know the last point
that you get the 0 0 the first argument
I'll owe you to do a translation okay
all right we'll come to this ok this
ridiculous me to dive into this
particular thing but somebody on our
live stream is asking if a Voronoi
measure for 3 D is being worked on it is
but it's not coming now part of what
we're doing by having polyhedra
polyhedron is needed as an actual cell
for mesh regions and the cells that's
produced by Voronoi mesh in 3d are
general polyhedra and so that's needed
there ok so it's coming but not not 1212
one
oh boy there's a lot of stuff here
so planar Angle is what's going to just
do three points right it's that's the
planar angle between three points yes
aha so if I say for example here if I
my polyhedron by dodecahedron thing
there if I say for example surface area
cool and now if you haven't held you'll
probably get a parameterised form or a
or whatever side length header length
well good that that was that was not the
most oh wait wait wait
how can it be linear in the edge length
why isn't it quadratic in the edge
length that's a good question
something weird I would suspect a bug
there and also why is it different why
is it a different functional form when
it's when it's got an either well that
could happen I suppose
well anyway never mind that that's I
mean obviously to look at um and and the
volume of this creature is this this is
a filled dodecahedron yes yes they're
all solid okay okay um Wow okay a lot of
stuff here
all right let's dig in here so let me
get some sense here of the polygons with
holes business that seems scary to me
mm-hmm that's polygons but I want to say
polygons you don't I
yes okay represents
guns with holes so what we've done
before we have a multi polygon since
before mm-hmm okay but that is
effectively a union of polygons indeed
okay so we can't just use lists so we
use a rule so the outer left and then
the inner so is the inner a comp of
complement type operation is this thing
called s yes that's definitely so so let
me understand this
okay so there's a list of things and
then there are complementary holes that
are popped out so if there's a lake on
an island on a lake do we get to say
that or does that not make any sense su
iterate you mean yeah I mean in other
words if I were to have in this case I
have a polygon and I punch a hole out of
the polygon right I mean it's still I
don't know if there is an immediate
direct way to do that of course it can
be represented it's not a problem it's
still a polygon you know I understand I
understand I understand
so okay so what is the what is the thing
that punches a hole out of a polygon
there must be an operation that does
that like polygon compliment or
something that given a given one polygon
region difference okay so in other words
if I say so if you're telling me if I
say triangle how do we have this if we
say SSS triangle now why doesn't that
make a it should make an equilateral
triangle what the hell is it doing why
isn't that making I think they're I
think that they're individual I don't
think that's a list okay okay fine so
there's a triangle so now if I say I
want to punch that triangle so I say
region difference of rectangle
and then percent 50 well actually what I
really want let me make those much
smaller okay I don't really know what
I'm doing I don't know exactly where
it's gonna land up but um okay
and now that's gonna be a little bit on
the corner
unfortunately okay so now if I say
graphics of that whoops what did that do
so first you are you know a silver key
on that we have engaged in you know here
it's still generating a boolean equation
so you have to do a rage on actually our
agent of each one protein okay that's
bug just do a region of 65 okay but
that's a bug right we agree yes well
whatever I don't know what I did here I
don't understand why that wouldn't have
punched it out um whatever I don't know
I don't exactly understand that but but
should that have given a polygon of the
whole as the canonical form or is that
part of canonicalized polygon that's
part of canonicalize polygon which
probably should be called canonicalize
polygon not canonical polygon I think I
may be wrong um okay so okay so I
understand what's going on here I think
so well you're saying this polygon now
what happens if there's if the Q sub I
are not planar with the P sub I well
what happens if the P sub I are not
planar in 3d what happens in in general
so in 3d in graphics it's sort of
undetermined what's happening it's
running a triangulation library and it
does something but you cannot predict
what it will do okay okay
so a non planar polygons is large
it's an undefined algorithmically
defined you know it's it's depends on
who implemented it
if Jill Bob one has a good mood today or
welcome by the way this is not marking
this is not tagging what's new in twelve
just a comment right is this new this
thing at the end yes so the idea is that
the that that case there is basically
like a complex like a graphics complex
right okay which is there it's part of
what the canonical thing will do the
other thing you have to remember we
can't prevent you or users from giving
loops to cross themselves sure okay
and it's no we can't also prevent you
from giving these inner loops that
either cross themselves across the outer
loop so there's a lot of things that can
go wrong with polygons and Polly heat or
even more okay but so this case is like
a graphics complex so you're saying yes
but so what is the form of data
typically okay should be down there and
those are just indices now yeah I
understand
um okay so what is this now outer
polygon points and inner polygon
boundary oh I see I see I see I see I
see so this is an inventory this is a
library of points to use and this is now
specifying the actual structure of the
of the polygons correct okay okay it's
reasonable enough um and this works
actually the same way for them for
polyhedra you see yeah I understand
which is nice um okay let me look at the
polyhedron page we've never had a
polyhedron page before that's right but
it's still called polyhedron new or not
it is no it's just put it on is the dead
page which is believed on you oh sorry
yes do you realize that we're not
beeping in real time anymore yes
needs to somehow to Mac user told me
that um okay polyhedron inside the
closed surfaces with polygon faces okay
so in other words if I give you so so
fundamentally what you're telling me is
if I say boy that's a big mess if I say
polyhedron data of rhombic whatever it
is Robert hexagon - hidden comma faces
that's a bit funky what do I want to
call it face coordinates or something I
don't know what is well what I was gonna
do is feed that into the polyhedron but
you can okay you can get the coordinates
in two faces and it will fit right in
how do I get the coordinates of the
faces done just ask for the coordinates
in palliative data vertices vertices
oh look at those those are very Swank
the first time I've seen those in the
wild
well those are nice you like those Roger
I do and we have something even cooler
for 12 one for what I'll talk about it
later
no hint no okay fine
okay that didn't work right because now
you need also their faces I know that's
what I thought I was going to generate
from this that's why I was trying Polly
he don't need both coordinates and faces
no I understand that I understand that
so I'm saying that this and presumably
that if I say this but this is very
weird that I have to do it this way
right
no I don't know what why don't you read
the documentation follow it so the first
position is points right the vertices
second position are the faces but this
says faces F sub I in Polly turn
coordinates , faces no it doesn't that's
what it just says right but you couldn't
get that data directly out of polyhedron
data I said it's okay you don't need
that in that form okay okay I mean you
probably can get it out I just don't
know what I understand but how are the
face is specified here the faces are
just a list of points okay so each one
is a face is a polygon okay it's
actually a polygon or it's a list of
points that wisdom points Lister points
could it could it also be polygons of
list of points should they soom so the
charts is that supported now or you know
you should probably go there I mean
there is nothing that you have to
propagate it all over the system for
polygons line point that's followed oh
I'm sorry no no no if you say it's got
faces we should be able to polyhedron
should be able to take symbolic polygons
as faces I agree but you have to do that
through the whole system uniformly your
member midpoint need to take that if it
you need to take point or line the same
for line Michael I need to take also
point
so we have that the whole system so but
I think but I would do it for polyhedra
because it's gonna be super confusing to
people immediately for polyhedron I mean
I agree you need to propagate it through
the whole system but I would make sure
it works with polyhedron okay um but
Stephen if you just want to make your
example work but then the one you
started and yeah yeah okay can we just
make that work yes I mean I thought I
was gonna make it work this way because
I was gonna make it work
I'm just surprised okay whosever Justine
is the person dealing with polyhedron
date oh yeah yeah yeah we with them yes
yes of course
okay all right so then how do I get can
we well if if you just to put it on
faces comma polygons who gives you that
now where's polygons here so project on
the fact Akito element so you can say
like you did faces and if you put coma
polygons they give you actual polygon
object okay this has to be better
documented well doesn't even say other
output types related to this it doesn't
even list it doesn't list polygons here
right yes okay so there's some cleanup
needed so this this is now no so the
first one should be vertices I thought
it should be faces faces you say
polygons there will that work because
then it probably comes out the polygon
it still don't work then you have to top
that right to hate so what do I do I say
polygons goes to identity I think okay
and now finally polyhedron right
is the levels are correct here I don't
know so now I say graphics 3d of this
splash no it's it it so there should be
this should be a there will be an
important it will get your polyhedron
out directly okay it doesn't right now
but it will I think there's one extra
level of list here that uh okay so
listen there's some cleaning up to be
done Charles with what polyhedron data
generates and maybe some other
properties for polyhedron data that
makes sense
yes discussing that video and apply okay
so are you telling me that if I now do
this and I do for example like a sphere
or something I can I can do the boolean
whatever it is of this with a how do I
get the size of the circumcised
circumradius of this bounding region of
the points but I don't know if that's
work it's not installed but if you have
the points just do bounding region of
the points and you'll get it well
actually I don't have the points here
because I have the I have I'd have to
get the vertices so it's a bit of a mess
okay so if I say bounding region
so that would give you a cuboid but then
you want a min ball yeah how do I get
that
stricka-- the second argument is min
ball of which for bounding region
bounding reading can produce many
different kinds of bounding regions and
you want the ball there it is that's
super cool okay so if I say so okay so
here's what I want to do I want to take
this and I want to do a boolean how do i
how do I chop I want to I want to
complement with that ball so I want this
thing I want this thing with its points
chopped off so what I'm saying yes
will that work now Charles is that all
installed no okay then okay but that
stuff is coming yes yes yes okay all
right so the fundamental point here by
the way I assume that the last level of
lists if I have only one hole is it the
case that I can drop the second layer of
lists on the complement both side of
polygons yes okay it's very interesting
this polygon whole thing is very
interesting I don't think I um okay okay
canonical polygons that will produce
whatever input you use to insert you
know so the input to polygon is rich but
if you're gonna compute with it you want
it in a form that's useful for
computation
that's what canonical problem by the way
I assume that um you know the famous
examples of South Africa with Lesotho
and things like that
that we're going to return these richer
polygons in the future from our um have
you talked to the geo people about that
yeah I'll say is ready to go when this
is live that's what he's gonna leverage
to build that layer for geography
wonderful wonderful yes yeah we've been
since the inception and before okay
alright canonical polygon do you really
think that's the right name as opposed
to canonicalize polygon or it's a little
weird it suggests it's a special polygon
so to speak as opposed to something that
takes a polygon I don't really have a
super strong opinion I think
canonicalize as in verb is not bad well
if I play Siddharth canonical coffered
or something similar
what does canonical graph do if a
canonical form of the class isomorphic
that is a very crazy message there gives
a canonical graph of the graph can I
change that gives a canonical form of
the graph yes
okay well what do you think I I must say
I'm a little bit weirded out by
canonical polygon but let's understand
what it does at least so what are the
different filters that you can use here
so one thing that can happen and that
that frequently happens is you get by
the way I'm sorry the filter
specifications that you come in here are
not strings so the quotes filter is the
wrong specification they're true it's
true minor point right you're right you
know so the main thing that's important
there we've built so so when you do
boolean operations it's not like if you
do boolean operations of 2d solids in
also areas mm-hmm what can happen is
that you get lower dimensional
components come out there can be line
segments that can be points mm-hmm for
instance also in our specification
allows you to specify these quotes
singular if you like polygons there are
just lines or just points now a lot of
operations you don't want to deal with
that and you want to work with what's
called a regular closure which is there
which it's the the interior it takes you
- interior I'm just gonna put that up
there because I'm sure it's a keyword
for this it is yes okay which you
compute the interior that blows away all
the lower dimensional stuff and then you
compute the closure and then you get the
boundary points to be included
okay so that's what school that's a
regular closure okay but the picture
you've showin here hmm I would have
expected that from canonical polygon no
I'm just saying you asked about filters
okay
that actually has nothing to do with the
filters okay the picture has to do with
a with the base case that everybody
thinks about you can think of it as
actual outer and actual inner okay even
if you don't specify it like that up
front okay like that star was generated
as one self crossing line yeah I mean
surely
yeah these examples are hardly stellar
without any pictures
agreed and also these examples where
they just give the same result back
again I'm kind of silly no different to
our current example if you want example
of canonical polygons on your review
notebook the examples there okay that's
a new function polygon coordinates yes
why are we doing it that way rather than
having a coordinate sub thing from a
polygon because you will be using it if
you if you actually directly compute and
a lot of people might want to do that
then you will be using it a lot
so question um my gosh that's new that's
exciting that's interesting it's good
idea now why didn't this come back as
one of those ought to canonicalize well
and also you know to avoid noise during
the government process we just did that
for the canonical version so if this is
our probe it probably will propagate it
everywhere if needed
so we want to call it polygon
so polygon points
polygon vertices polygons isn't a
polygon vertices but means the actual do
actual output our coordinate right if we
see point you should return point
vertices well vertices would be either
but I mean that's if okay question I
mean we do not have right now sub values
for the do we have sub values for any of
these geometric things or regions for
example now we have some that not really
documented to use it or there's some in
Reichle somewhat there are some sub
value in the way job okay would you
consider having some values for polygon
no not really from the experience from
question you know didn't work that
nicely so but it's possible I mean it
okay so a segment so I might am I to
understand that we have both polygon
coordinates and polyhedron coordinates
as two separate functions yes is that a
good idea well so really they are they
really you know kind of simpler forms of
boundary meshes you know boundary mesh
regions the I think that it is just is
triple of functions polygon coordinates
inner polygon outer polygon and the same
thing for polyhedra same triple or you
know in the canonical for I guess yeah
that's I think that you're not were
concerned about the fact that we're
gonna have something which is I mean
okay naive question I mean if we started
to have like CAD like things where
there's a instead of a polyhedron it's
something defined by you know NURBS or
something like that some some creature
defined by NURBS
hmm um well so here's a concern
okay I think that where we built up you
know for part of what we had rich is
mesh region boundary mesh region and
those are gonna get richer still um but
I still think from people's mind there's
a whole group of people that think
polygon is the whole world mm-hmm okay
and I think this is appeals to them you
can do a lot of computations directly on
there but you're proposing then that the
fancier stuff like random nub
created things are boundary mesh regions
right okay there will be probably a new
object because mesh will probably stay
linear and once you go nonlinear it's
it's it's a it's a new object again okay
because they're gonna have other issues
yeah okay all right but you're proposing
okay I get it at least okay can I try
this with uh with that just for the hell
of it no it didn't work oops
well I get rid of oh I got rid of it too
many layers right oh you had it correct
sorry okay okay so dick polygons that
you get back from these are what these
are simple polygons they are they're
homeomorphic to a disk yeah oh well not
always right how do I get be like the
holiness of this Euler characteristic
whatever you call it of this thing do
you mean for put on it hello catalystic
yeah it's the same thing or the
characteristic for a polygon isn't it
yes we just have four put yet one so far
why don't we have other characteristics
for polygons it's perfectly happy
there's a holiness count for those two
but so so there's a function Euler
characteristic that just gives this is
that right yes it doesn't give the holes
it gives the Euler characteristic no I
understand which in this case would be
what two or something I don't know how
they count what about genus I mean isn't
that we also have Virginia's but for
polygons so far so we can list end okay
make it work for polygons it'll be
easier to document um we don't have a
thing called genus what is it what is it
what is it call put on gymnast I think
we should just have a thing called genus
is there any reason not to do that
well region genus okay but I don't know
if we can compute it for regions in
general I see I mean we will eventually
but well okay so initially you want to
have polygons genus polyhedron genus
separately is that the idea yeah I think
it's fine I mean eventually we may be
able to have a more general genus thing
yes um okay by the way somebody on our
live stream asked was kind of a separate
question a while ago come on finally
import-export polygons and regions to
STL files with textures
no not currently STL doesn't support
texture I hope you genius obj yes but we
support it when possible so far sweets
okay but I think there was one thing we
needed to update wasn't there it was the
texture support for meshes yes okay if
you carried in the normal coffee right
okay so with this supported where it's
supported in the objects and the
external objects also internally so you
we can you can import it and get the
graphics complex and you get the texture
mm-hmm but you're saying for the mesh
for boundary for regions we don't yet
have textures right
we don't mesh us which is the one that
would be relevant don't support textures
texture coordinates right now become a
convert from a mesh to a graphics
complex yes using what show okay and
then you can have textures yes okay this
is another complaint that this doesn't
work is a union so yeah what John dothis
Mosby have you written walking you
should work
okay wave it so that this is something
that's coming in this version or not
well these version on your necks okay
there's a question about
high-performance 3d graphics yes that's
coming but not for this just not um not
this discussion okay somebody is
commenting that biological genius is
better known and we shouldn't probably
use the word genus yeah to represent
good point yeah that's a good point
I mean ultimately it should be region
genus probably or geometric or
topological genus may be the correct
term is topological genus yeah
to it okay I think it'd be nice to start
having some functions that have topology
in their name yes there's a whole slew
of things for topology coming like what
and a lot of things related to algebraic
and algebraic topology and combinatorial
topology okay all right so okay and we
have a bunch of other things already in
point-set topology like if you go to
semi cylindrical decomposition it's
actually we support point-set topology
operations for same algebraic sets
cylindrical decomposition yeah now if
you scroll down there okay these stop
alert up top go up go up go one more up
there okay topological operations under
a closure interior exterior closure but
no idea we added these Wow I mean that's
wait a second so that means I mean those
are pretty non-trivial things I'm
surprised that those are hidden down in
the properties here because we're gonna
bring it out in a more broad sense
there's this one corner of it that needs
to be a lot more support okay but this
is basically taking yes they're non
trivial right but I mean so what this
allows want to do I mean in your
polyhedron thing you would be able to
take cylindrical details I don't wanna
do that
okay you don't want to do that do what
you don't want to use cylindrical
decomposition for polyhedra no no I
understand but given that you've got a
solution set from cylindrical
decomposition you could you know turn
that into a polyhedron that you can then
compute with it quite impossible if you
have it in empty seat where Java you
call canonical ideas I mean that's you
have to be an implicit well anyway let's
not let's not go that right now right
okay I have a long discussion about that
okay I don't fine that's not dear dear
Ellis
okay winding numbers and things is there
some okay so let's look at outer polygon
does outer polygons have some kind of
way of disabilities no no no these are
very utility things
okay so outer polygons it if it's if it
already it isn't already canonicalized
it will canonicalize first okay and then
that defines what the outer polygon is
what does the canonicalization operation
do again it does a number of things but
you see the example given there with a
star mm-hmm those points where it
crosses there now those have to be
computed oh I see so it starts as a
polygon with the winding with just a
bowtie ish polygon right then it can be
other definitions of polygons which
you'll see that we also support okay
there are different ways to give meaning
to polygons particularly when there are
non simple went across themselves yes
and they define different regions okay
so they're constructors down there a
crossing polygon and a winding polygon a
random polygon I'm still not by the way
completely sold on this plane canonical
polygon okay can you explain more what
canonical polygon really is I mean it's
a polygon I understand it's been
canonicalized in some way where it's
been explicitly written as a polygon
polygon component type thing yes so so
there is one key thing is that you can
have civil way to I mean one polygon
geometric rajanya now to for example you
can describe it in save our form just
using our ways pressure on polygon so
canonical polygons first allow you to
have a stand out or presentation in you
know one unique expression yes what we
also we do is that we can only collide
for example the coordinate which are
sorted and then you have the indices and
from that you can actually deduce a lot
of operation of result filtration from
sample to duplicate coordinate our
search
okay it kind of does the cleanup for you
before you actually start to manipulate
the object reasonable enough all right
let's take a look at some of these other
ones so the definition
or crossing polygons is if you put up if
you pick a point now that point is in
the polygon if you draw a ray to
infinity any direction and the number of
times you cross the boundary curve is
odd okay yeah okay so it has a point
away from from the point representing
all points which array from the point in
any direction the plane crosses the
segment's so that means what any of
these corner points right but now to get
it to totally unambiguous you should not
pick a corner point you should you know
you'll cross a corner point with
probability 0 it has measure 0 if you
pick one array at random ok and you can
surely pick one that doesn't cross them
if you cross them you need to compensate
correctly so don't do it it's there
simple ok ok so now the definition is
unambiguous and that works exactly the
same way for a polyhedron for crossing
polygons for crossing polyhedron it
works in higher dimensions than that in
any dimension actually by the way what
are we doing five dimensions beyond
three are we gonna have poly tope
eventually we eventually yes ok but
clearly it's more important to get
really good coverage in 2d and 3d sure
ok now the other new thing here for this
one if you if you look at the two
triangles down there yeah
our definition a polygon that we
instituted in canonicalized on in
version 6 you know so you had the same
definition everywhere and print out and
screen and different platforms yes is
the one that's called polygon it treats
multiple loops as a union however you
can very well treat them as just loops
in this condition where you put array to
infinity and that's what crossing
polygons does
so it doesn't a less naive and richer
construction and it would produce a
polygon L that is Jack any other polygon
so it's a constructor okay here's the
thing I'm missing so I understand let's
see okay so these curves so this is just
P 1 this is the line segment but these
are P 1 2 P 2 1 I think you I think oh I
see this is a higher dimension no I'm
totally confused here a line segment
just has is defined by two points Y is
the same P 1 1 P 1 2 dot dot dots I
think that's wrong
think you want to say crossing polygon a
P 1 1 P 1 2 then P 2 1 P 2 2 I'm not
right what I'm saying not sure look look
look look these polit the line segments
what this is doing right it's just
breaking this as partition 2 comma 1
right now so those are the faces of the
polygon if you like you know the edge
yes yes right but what this is saying is
these line segments if you had more than
two points in this line say this thing
it isn't a straight line made up it's
made up of edges to face the segments
this is if the full the full closed
contour we want to specify its kind of
DiMucci form like you have input it on
what you have at least oh I see I see
it's the multiform but it's interpreted
differently that's what I was trying to
tell you you know this is very confusing
so what you want to say here this is
this is confusing let me understand
something other ones first
okay you're not trying to get to I mean
I'm sorry I'm just gonna ask a matter
question because I didn't fully
understand what you were talking about
there you're not trying to stuff two
different definitions into one crossing
polygon thing are you
no it's the same condition that I said
with array exactly the same condition
but even that first line of
illustrations there look at that last
example yes it has three closed contours
mm-hmm okay
and they all viewed you know when you
decide what points are in it that Ray
condition is still applied to all of
those contours mm-hmm okay
whereas in polygon that would just be a
solid rectangle because they're viewed
as a union yeah I understand okay
it's different okay so I don't
completely understand the word crossing
polygon it's it's it's ray crossing is
it a standard name it's it's it's
yesterday crossing yeah okay okay let's
keep going
we have some questions on our live
stream about will this be useful for
today you have your lakes example you
know where you stand
right okay this allows you to do that
very easily okay the lake on an island
let's see this is now the comments on
our live stream about calculating about
defining a polygon by having the polygon
vertices in counterclockwise order is
that what winding polygon is gonna do
right so why do you put it on depending
on the orientation on there right yes
you can specify that is in 1d particle
it doesn't matter for crossing polygon
no I understand represent polygons which
the closed contour whines around at
least one you mean once not one right
once
closed contour rounds winds around at
least once boy it's hard for me to
understand the stuff
can we change over to my screen for just
a bit Steven and I think it would be
useful for you and for the audience
everybody okay
all right hold on one second here I
suppose see I'm just excited by random
polygons I just wanna see what that is
and then we can look at your screen
Roger okay oh wow that's a cool idea
that's a really cool idea so so if I say
graphics 3d of that I'll get I actually
will get all of those three polygons in
the same Oh classics graphics graphics
now what if I wanted 3d polygons we have
the second tag document a PDF which
gives the dimension you can actually get
them in 42 if you feel if you feel like
it so that just gives the number of
polygons but how many how many sides to
the polygons have here there to say the
second argument is the number of sides
so you can't do convex coma three five
we gives you a number of points wait
wait wait wait wait but three I thought
that was the number of polygons the
second argument yes that you can put in
common no convex you can put it in a
list you know leagues all right okay so
there are a random hexagons cleaner yes
because all polygons are okay yes
well we've never been able to do this
halfway getting polygons getting random
polygons in 3d but a guaranteed planar
right actually much more interesting is
if you do simple okay what's the point
of that now so they're still simple but
they're not convex right oh I see what's
that you know what the heck is that
I think he's laundering the buff feeling
before the hunt I'm a tortoise you know
that too close together right Polly kept
feeling white that only comes in when
you do opacity so I don't think so
I think it's a bug so I send you this
collection of polygons yes I talk to you
okay I just said you that that cell um
okay
hold on oops this is not so easy why is
this taking so long
oh that's really weird did it just
render this that's crazy crazy it just
rendered this as a graphic oh you know
what I should do why doesn't that offer
to at the cell level it should offer to
UM copy as input text right but why
didn't it do that up there when I
selected the graphic
that would seem to me to be a minor bug
um okay let's let's watch Rogers screen
then I I'm not completely convinced by
the way in terms of this documentation
you really should put something which
indicates that there's this list ending
at the top here and also not at all
convinced that the dimension D should be
a third argument like that I think the
dimension D should be something that is
somehow part of you know more like D
arrow whatever it is here for instance
making sense because think the D is like
a critical piece of the brand Impala con
well I would suggest to something more
like this and a polygon you know three
arrow ten for three-dimensional ten ten
sided polygons which means that you'd
end up with things like um three arrow
convex ten and things which seems to me
much does that make sense to you guys I
think that's better think so because you
rarely gonna specify it that's why what
you know I mean I guess to 3ds is it's
very mainstream higher D it's not so
mainstream sure it's gonna end up being
you know 300 10 means in 3d make me ten
things right but the 3d is very
mainstream so you don't want it as a
third argument after having a one there
mm-hmm okay make sense
pretty good point yeah yeah okay let's
watch your screen okay
so here you guys see yep okay so I'm
just gonna spend a little bit of time
but then we'll understand all of these
definitions much better I think okay and
so so here's the ray that we know called
crossing polygon Roger yeah what are you
doing with these documents are these
gonna find their way into the notebook
archive at some point because there's
really a lot of great material here they
did Drive a lot of our development
yeah anyway okay all right I like the P
do you know the Roger encyclopedia yeah
sure um okay so okay so
so first of all we need to sort of I'm
gonna define the Ray crossing which we
talked about so we have a piece for
polygon we have a piecewise linear curve
right in our to the Ray crossing counted
the number of times array from P to
infinity any type infinity crosses see
okay that contour so now we can define
for instance a polygon array crossing
polygon is two points for which that ray
count is odd
are we going to have this function or a
cross and count we do actually okay so
if you scrolled in that design notebook
that I sent its lit just a few lines
below
okay now if I have multiple contours
you know so I have multiple of these
clothes contours mmm then you know the
rate crossing count is the total number
of times the rate crosses any of these
contours and now I defined that polygon
very much the same way to say I'm saying
I'm just saying that the count is gonna
be odd okay okay so that gives you an
algorithm and let's skip that for now
but now we can do you know so here's a
question is when they are similar so
this is a simple polygon
and it's behaves like you think you know
so these guys have a crossing count of
one crossing only one so it's in
here's a simple but sorry there was a
convex polygon there's a simple polygon
and here is a non simple polygon okay so
in here I'm crossing
and crossing two times right so those
points in there are out yeah those are
in its function random membership plot
should make it to the function
repository right okay now here's the
case with at multiple contours
mmm-hmm see again the rule works right
you pick a point here I'm crossing twice
it's gonna be out okay here I'm crossing
once it's gonna be in raid it goes in
the other direction I'm gonna crossed
three times it's still in so I'm saying
it doesn't matter what direction I get
it yep get it okay
and now we can complicate it again for
us we can have so here is a non simple
one inside of a simple one but the rule
still works we can have multiple of
these and it gets more complicated
okay what is an angle polygon coming to
that it's that's what's called a winding
polygon now but let me just before it go
there I'm gonna just do ray crossing in
3d so we see that it works out exactly
the same way and here so I have so
a closed oriented surface
they're multiple surfaces yeah okay I
can see this is gonna work
yeah okay but you see it's gonna work
out exactly the same way you know the
rate crossing count is going to be odd
okay and the examples come out exactly
the same way you know I have a simple
even convex polyhedron you see these
blue points inside are in the ones that
red they're out
but not comebacks and so on and so forth
okay you get these multiple nested once
and you have a way to determine what's
in and what's out a comment from our
livestream is make sure to handle custom
polygon vertices properly in other words
I guess if we hit yes the Rays go
through yeah yes okay so they're two
ways of handling that one is that you in
one way is that you derive a calculus
for how to compensate for it properly
and you can kind of pull through that in
2d 3d it gets very complicated because
get edges and vertices both to deal with
as boundary cases but you can better do
is that if you hit one of those you're
going to hit one of those with
probability 0 you pick a different Ray
you start over
okay you mean publicity what if you if
you hit if you pick the Ray that it so
happens to go through a point yes you
can detect that you start over you pick
a different ray and you're gonna hit one
you probably know you're not gonna hit
one same if you hit the net we are fair
enough
okay now angle polygon this is the other
way common way to define a polygon and
I'm gonna use nomenclature now that's
gonna generalize to 3d so but you're
gonna like it in the end
okay so hmm see this is it's just a
different way of just a way of defining
angle so I want to see for an edge for a
segment for a face of the polygon or an
edge as we call it professor
okay this is the subtended angle so
here's a point that I want to figure out
whether it's gonna be inside and I want
to see what the edge what's the angle is
that's obtained by that edge yep okay
that is the angle as a traverse that
okay and it's oriented yep okay and we
can go different directions right by the
way isn't there a Geo analogue of that
computation maybe I think it's the
version between grid and grid
coordinates and that long coordinates or
some such other thing okay anyway okay
go on so we have a now an angle measure
so I'm going to define that angle
measure so I have a like we did before I
have a closed contour piecewise-linear
let's say and it's oriented and then the
angle measure is that I'm adding up with
sine what the measures are so I take
each segment in this case positive or if
I go this way and I just add those up
okay that's my that's my angle measure
now now that I know what the angle
measure is of the boundary we just back
to that point that I'm checking mm-hmm
now the only if if I have a simple so
the boundary doesn't cross itself the
only possible values that that measure
can have is these -2 PI 0 and 2 pi and
if it's not simple meaning it crossing
itself then it's any integer multiple of
2 pi
ok ok so that's what can happen now now
I can use this so I define a polygon so
a point is in it if that angle measure
respect to that point is not zero
I'm saying yeah okay okay okay okay I
get it
yep now I can also do if I have multiple
closed and oriented curves I just add
all of them up together you know I get
something for multiple closed curves
just as we did for Ray crossing I did a
case for multiple closed curves
all right so you know I
I get this but ok ok we will weaken I'm
a Steven we're gonna do this for
polyhedra next I just want to do this
base case better ok so it behaves like
you think it is
you know people learn like rules like
put your finger in the middle and sort
of wind around and so how many times
does a rubber you know it to count the
angles but you see these points are in
because I'm gonna wind around once so
it's actually 2 pi for any of these
points
I think by the way the person on a live
stream is talking about
if polygon is to test all the plugins
inside take two points in order and the
polygons together with a random point to
calculate if they make it clockwise or
counterclockwise turn is that equivalent
to this or is that not equivalent to
this
in other words if you sit inside a
polygon and you look at the polygon
vertices in order hmm I think that
that's gonna come out to be equivalent
because there many ways to get I picked
an explanation here i did it this
traditional way and then i redid it so
that it fits to 3d case okay okay so
that's why i'm done it this way okay
okay and and it behaves this one is you
know one thing to note here for the rate
crossing case these inner points would
have been out these blue points in that
middle
um middle middle part here there there
would be excluded if you use right
crossing
included with you I go I go okay yep and
and likewise you can get one of
situations where all this stuff really
matters I mean I understand it's
different different communities have
different conventions for what they
really like is there polygons definition
and so for some people it doesn't matter
that much but Adobe for instance support
both both what we call hair winding or
angle I remember right early PostScript
that was the case right but they call it
fill rule because it's that's they don't
really compute with it they only sort of
fill gem saying it's it's a they care
about it do they care about it because
they try to make a letter a with a hole
in the middle of it they do care about
it
yeah for that reason I mean that's
phonce well then yes that's one reason
that's probably why they had it early on
I suspect actually hmm how do we do part
fonts I mean when you take a font and we
we import it it becomes a they filled
curve or filled curve does exactly this
you know with a ray crossing case
okay but our field curve is what it's
one of these build curve no-frill curve
is like an Metta primitive you can have
lines and Bezier curves and b-spline
curves as segments yeah I understand
that but how does it know what the
inside is it alternately discretize this
and using the it for polygons
- sure I'm saying it discretize the sofa
that you can't see it it's at a pixel
resolution okay but I mean if you have a
letter a with a hole a capital A with a
hole in the middle okay say with the
hole in the middle you're saying that it
is I mean doesn't it have to assemble
that from coordinate patches basically
yeah but it uses if you import it and
use it as a graphics primitive to render
it a big size otherwise the system does
that the operating system does it and we
don't do it no I understand that but I'm
asking if in this model what you're
defining here you could make an a that
is a single polygon is that true that's
true okay and it's done in typical I've
no idea I mean I I don't know the
details of how fonts and you know type
one versus two type versus whatever else
I don't know the details of how those
you know how those are represented but
is it they use b-spline curves you know
so they're they're true type font uses
b-spline curves the the Adobe used
bezier curves I think yeah yeah right
okay fair enough all right okay keep
going
yeah okay so and here's how this comes
out you know here's two closed contours
and this applying this rule they're all
in mmm okay and you can see how all the
different cases so it's it for simple
polygons everything agree when you get
to non simple multiple counts count
herbs they they disagree the different
definitions
different ways of defining what's what
the set is Jim I'm saying what's in it
how it's filled let's do the 3d case and
then we're done okay there are many
other kinds of polygons here that we're
not going to talk about okay
now since we did it since I did the
derivation with it with an angle segment
to a unit circle now you can see what
this obtained did angle this is a solid
angle is from a sphere so at the point
is at the center of the sphere and how
much does this polygon subtend from that
sphere hmm you see that and they can
also be oriented so these are two or
different measures here yep okay that
means that we've defined what the angle
measure is right with respect for up for
a polygon with respect to a point yes
okay so now hmm so for a closed polygon
an oriented polygon surface it's it's we
just compute the total angle measure for
each phase
sir I'm saying yeah yeah okay nine we'd
say so they're signed angle yo solo
gonna sign solid angles yep okay and you
if you have multiple surfaces then you
just total up each surface on its own
which itself then tolls up each polygon
yep okay
I can define a polygon sorry polyhedron
so they're all first of all they're only
possible if it's a simple polyhedron the
only possible measures it can take are
these minus 4 PI 0 & 4 pi
just as in the polygon case the only
possible values was minus 2 pi 0 & 2 pi
and if it's not simple if it crosses
itself it can be any multiple of 4 pi
makes sense yes ok
so now we define that polyhedron what a
point is in it if the angle measure is
nonzero
you know and it's the same for when I
get it I get it I go this is beautiful
right it's very nice so now so doser um
you know those are kind of key and now
we can do a bunch of examples for that
and then we're done okay Roger
um practicality I am supposed to go to
some other meeting right now we clearly
have a fair amount more to do for this
right we will set up another one okay
we'll meet you how long do we hang we're
gonna need two hours at least I think I
think so too
um can we just scope out could let me
get them I get my screen back for a
second let this just show up out what we
have to look at um okay convex polygon
simple polygon Q it's reasonable enough
okay um polygon decomposition so many
many algorithms what they need is that
you have an algorithm that can only work
for triangles you have an algorithm that
can only work for convex polygons you
have an algorithm that can only work for
simple polygons so now if you have
something more complicated you got to
break it down into these things but I
think this should say polygon decompose
because I think this is returning the
actual decomposition whereas usually
when we have something called
decomposition it gives an object that
represents you get what I'm saying well
you could argue both ways you know if
you say Lu decomposition it gives the
actual decomposition Jordan
decomposition gives yeah I was thinking
of those examples but that they give
sort of a package is assemble into the
decomposition whereas this is actually
decomposing the polygon into convex
pieces right but you can assemble it by
Union well I understand that but well
whatever I mean I I'm not opposed to
whatever you know I think polygons
decompose might be better for this but
I'm not sure um
okay
so now you're going to see that the
polyhedron case follows exactly pretty
much exactly
you
okay so are you saying that uniform
polyhedron takes all the strings that
are in Pali he didn't data now only unit
only ones that are uniform polyhedra so
there are things that are not there and
all the things that they are the same
okay
polyhedron data doesn't include all the
uniform polyhedra unfortunately how many
more other choice was to count I'll pull
it on data date I mean it's hard to
actually build them is what we are
building now so put it on data just have
22 of them excluding the infinite family
Chris Monty prism so that's 25 we are
building all the 475 okay great are we
getting exact coordinates for them and
all kinds of crazy stuff like that yes
painful but yes um this is this crazy
bounding box as you again for 3d
graphics we keep on talking about this
so YouTube is implementing another thing
for to give you the way you can give the
actual sphere that you want as the
bounding okay okay okay that will solve
the molecule case because if he just he
just had points right he can use
bouncing to get that sphere and now he
can call graphics appropriately and it
will be what you want excellent
so using the min ball business and
things like that exactly that's
beautiful
is that efficient yes very okay okay all
kinds of angle measures terrific we
looked at a couple of these alright okay
so just to scope this out okay graphs
and networks we did we we did the review
of that right we did yes
okay so unity link is another probably
is that a one to two hour design review
at least yes but they will all come this
week okay okay um okay well alright so
another two hours probably on all of the
stuff um okay wonderful
alright um let's wrap it up here thanks
to folks on the livestream and by the
way for those on the livestream our
marathon session continues with natural
language processing coming up next
um alright I will commit these changes
in a few minutes okay yeah okay traffic
alright talk to y'all soon